Philip forsberg but has yet to score
a goal this season and that's part of
the reason that Nashville is one and
three to start they had change over
when Barry trotz took over they traded Ryan
Johansson they bought out matu Shane that's
a lot of offense that uh they changed over
McCarron Aid checked there nice play by gson
good takeaway heed with it Rangers have not
been able to generate all that much offense
here in the first period Barry with a drive
same rebound put in a diving effort by Cole
Smith and didn't here's the play there to heel
and heel just loses control of it there's the
turnover and it leads to this Nashville comes the
other way Big Shot comes through and then Smith
just uh reaches behind shurin he's the only one
that saw the puck it just barely gets by shurin
I believe it was deflected in that's why shurin
had a little bit of an issue with it but Smith
just Dives after the loose Puck and puts it in
you don't hear much from Peter lulet although you
just did on that two on one hear him say wake up
guys that's shot by paner to save by sorrow this
Rangers Power Play DeAndre Miller pass deflected
played off the last by kako took a hard hit from
I quit Miller toight it missed and Smith with
a takeway breaks it all alone save a beautiful
G say no it went in it went in I thought he had
it I apologize on that oh I thought just Durkin
got it but it was Cole Smith second of the game
right over the stick a gustus look at that right
over his stick and onto the Stick of Smith who
had just come out of the Penalty Box Nashville
said we haven't had a lot of breaks in the first
four games and boy was that a nice break for them
coming out the box right onto the did not catch
the head coach's job last year right and was the
power play coach for the New Jersey Devils that's
right good hockey man a great job there helping
them uh reach New Heights underway second Curry
Jo to look for here quick shot to stop by sh tro
on the face off on with Barkley goodro Jacob
trouba and Ryan lingren oy to forsburg down
low score Ryan oy off a brilliant pass by aveng
alista and Nashville with a power play goal now
leads three to nothing you'll see the the winning
face off right there and now they start moving it
around one two three four in the net wow that
is beautiful passing and that's for a power
play that's been struggling so O'Reilly wins
the face off sent in by kie and Soros out to
get it take away good play that shot by kako a
save by Soros turnover zaros plays it goes off
a skate and beautiful really a good play by troch
gets the hit dislodges face off win by heel tuble
with a shot save the rebound wide by Miller hard
shot good shot by trouba I'll tell you what keep
for Sherwood came over and did a really good job
diving as Miller was getting the rebound and Aon
fought off the check from Cole Smith that the
flex Pops in the air and as still able to clear
it out Carri a made the play Rangers right back
in laier Rangers have picked it up here pan tried
to get it to Miller Smith broke it up here's a
breakaway chance Parson and moves in and a save by
sister might have got the hands as well and Miller
couldn't get the shot on goal and then there's the
turnover and Parson it Nashville one for two on
the power play Ry scored it earlier in this period
horberg Cho on with good throw and forsberg with
a big Drive beats just stking up [Applause] high
Nashville with two Power Play Goals here in
the second period now with a 4 nothing lead
power play much but he does a forsberg does a
good job getting knocked down getting back up
and then he just just decided a rifle you know
at some point he he came in leading this team
in shots on goal with 17 or with 18 pardon
me and didn't have a goal Rangers five shots
on goal in the first period seven here in the
second FEI gets room quick shot kicked Away by
Sorrows that's his best save of the game
Nick ponito with a Chance 50 seconds to
go in the period benaron looks toward
the net gets it back saah Jad fox in
the Chris [Applause] score looks like it'll be
Fox's goal it's deflected off the defenseman
Adam Fox it's a power play goal Ryan mcdna
McD's 27 in white he'll end up on the other
side to his right there he goes SL SES to
block it deflex off him just inside the far
post and that's a power play goal there
it is hits his left leg and Def Flex in
he can't believe it but the Rangers are on the
board here's one more look hits the skate left
skate I got to get Octavio in here Rangers
on a power play 45 seconds remaining of the
man Advantage got a score a five on four four
fox has it now krider pass Sol Smith reverses
to MCD gave it away it's a bandage hand to Fox
Fox to panarin try to get it back was blocked
by siss panan to Fox he's got room Fox takes it
around the net Savanah Jag now panarin fox looks
toward the end shoot saved by Soros brought in
on the right side it's Sherwood save by quick
rebound Punk wide they going to R paner for the
board tro swings it around it goes by zanah Jad
Fox gets over zanah Jad to paner and it hit the
crossbar and stayed out Fox to aanad who shoots
saved by Soros the lead to yakob Tran back to
Roman Yosi in front the flection save quick
G he has the puck outstanding defensive play
the stop the move by Philip forsberg will KY
pass the flex in front and Pok in into the body
of of troch will kie gets it across there's a
defle yeah you see what you see what SOS does
with his stick yeah that's offside review it
was determined the puck did not enter the Zone
before the ranger player therefore we're offside
no goal there's another one taken off the board
the Rangers had two the other night left it for
Zan J back to crder who shoots save rebound kako
couldn't get the shot on goal and was blocked
away that's yaku trended one-handed shot
it got underneath quick went wide and this
one winds down and the Nashville Predators
who last time they were here at the Garden
lost 7 nothing last March uh get exract some
Revenge as they come out with a strong effort